certains et
vous avez vu la ceinture sera peut-être
une ceinture
votre perception
votre tête est ce que vous savez où ce
que vous savez pas peut-être une
ceinture de catch pour certains vous
reconnaître que c'est une ceinture de
boxe pour ceux qui ont déjà vu cette
ceinture
vous saurez à qui elle appartient pour
moi personnellement ce sera le symbole
d'un enfant qui a un jour initié un rêve
et qu'il a accompli pour la personne à
qui elle appartient c'est beaucoup plus
que ça c'est le simple c'est le symbole
de son chemin qu'il a parcouru depuis le
jour où il a décidé d'en faire son
objectif parce qu'au final c'est un
objectif c'est un rêve mais c'est devenu
un objectif
et au final c'est des moments difficiles
des risques pris des doutes des
sacrifices des vraiment des difficultés
rencontrées mais c'est aussi des
réussites évidemment vu qu' il est
devenu champion du monde lorsqu'il a
lorsqu'il a eu cette ceinture là ça a
été déjà partagé de la fierté
pourquoi je vous parle de finalement ce
champion des champions
en fait c'est juste pour se poser la
question 2 qu'est ce qui a permis un
jour à cet humain d'accomplir finalement
son rêve parce que ça c'est quelque
chose qui nous intéresse tous et pour ça
je me suis dit on va des composés ça et
on va tout va bien analyser son chemin
d'une certaine manière
pour analyser le chemin bas en fait je
vais vous dire de commencer par la faim
et la faim c'est quoi ben pour pouvoir
être champion du monde il faut gagner il
faut gagner un combat il faut gagner un
combat le jour j oui on va parler
d'entraînement de préparation etc mais
finalement on est champion que si on a
un jour si on fait un jour un combat
pour ce titre face à un adversaire
finalement qu'est-ce qui va falloir
faire c'est quoi la boxe parce que là
c'est de la boxe et du calme exactement
ça va être d'être jugé vainqueur
et pour être jugé vainqueur il faudra
que un des deux athlètes qui fasse il a
deux options en fait soit il aura un
nombre de touches efficace supérieur à
celui de son adversaire
soit il le met ko en gros il a tellement
été efficace que en face son adversaire
n'a plus pu rendre des coûts ok
maintenant c'est pas si simple
et l'objectif va être finalement de
pour cet athlète
de ne pas être focalisé sur le fait de
gagner ne pas être focalisé sur le fait
d'être vainqueur il va devoir faire
quelque chose chose que justement les
athlètes ont du mal où on a du mal quand
on a un résultat quand on a un objectif
c'est que souvent on vise l'objectif et
c'est pas ça qui nous mène au résultat
c'est surtout de rester finalement
focaliser sur soi et de ne surtout pas
se focaliser sur tout ce qu'il ya autour
de soi
donc rester
dans sa zone de contrôle et sa zone de
contrôle c'est qui c'est quoi ces soi
et ça c'est pas toujours simple on le
sait
maintenant
j'ai envie d'aller plus loin et de poser
la question mais finalement ça veut dire
que chaque action qu'il va faire va être
essentiel pour atteindre son objectif
chaque action
donc comment faire pour que son action
une action
soit finalement efficace comment être
performant dans ses actions et dans une
seule action j'ai envie de vous prendre
un exemple
un exemple concret qui est ben voilà son
adversaire va faire une attaque attaque
du brave en gros est la faute de luis
attaque du brave hockey
faudra qu'il soit efficace le but en
boxe est touché mais c'est surtout de
pas se faire toucher aussi
ok qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête
de notre champion
c'est là où on voit que notre tête
et nos mécanismes et c'est grâce aux
sciences cognitives justement en
neurosciences à comment fonctionne et
découverte de notre fonctionnement qu'on
se rend compte à quel point on est à la
fois tout simule similaire pardon on est
aussi tous très différents
similaire dans notre mécanisme et c'est
là aussi où on retrouve finalement
l'intelligence artificielle qui a qui
essaye de
dupliquer un dupliquer finalement ce qui
se passe dans notre cerveau
parce qu'on est un rouage qui est très
bien fait qui sait très bien s'adapter
qui sait très bien apprendre et pour
cela il se passe alors je vais le
décomposer finalement en quatre étapes
il se passe une chose pour que d'abord
il puisse bien réagir et bien le cerveau
le cerveau nous j'ai envie de dire nous
notre système il a d'abord besoin de
voir la tacc d'avoir une prise
d'information ok si je vois pas qui a un
coût qui arrive si je les ai pas un
niveau de ma vision ça va être difficile
de l'anticiper on perd ce sera
hasardeuse donc il y aura une prise
d'information en premier et ça c'est une
récepteurs sensoriels qui permette notre
hui notre touché notre odorat la vision
ensuite c'est là où on va voir une fois
que la formation est prise c'est notre
cortex notre système est exactement j'ai
envie de dire qui prend le relais
et ce relais c'est le traitement de
l'information
en gros on va prendre l'information
extérieure et derrière on va vérifier
nos capacités à pouvoir réagir
correctement à cette information
extérieure et cette capacité là eh ben
c'est un mélange et c'est là où les
algorithmes sont là et sont présents
c'est un mélange d'énormément de
variables et énormément j'en ai montré
que quelques unes il y en a énormément
et on les connaît pas toutes encore en
gros le cerveau il va faire une chose
c'est qu'il va aller prendre les
expériences passées par rapport à cette
attaque et il va voir laquelle est la
plus adéquate positivement un résultat
positif pour pouvoir répondre maintenant
ça dépend aussi de son état énergétique
parce que s'il est en début de combat ou
en fin de combat on n'aura pas la même
capacité à agir on va avoir aussi la
posture du corps si je suis dans cette
position où si je suis complètement dans
cette position lui que ça va très très
vite si j'ai les deux pieds joints ça va
pas du tout être la même donc il y aura
une analyse de ou est-ce que j'en suis
qu'est ce que je fais pour pouvoir
répondre à cette attaque ensuite tu
auras la prise de décision est
finalement l'action on envoie
l'information pour qu'on puisse répondre
et réagir à cette action ok très bien
donc finalement
qu'est-ce qui différencie parce que ce
mécanisme on l'a tous qu'est ce qui
différencie c'est là qu'est ce qui
différencie ce champion du monde et
finalement quelqu'un ici qui n'a jamais
fait de boxe
bat c'est justement ce qui s'est passé
donc dans ses expériences passées il a
eu de l'entraînement de la pratique il a
vécu d'autres combats il a eu des
mécanismes qui se sont préparés à cette
action-là en répétant en apprenant et ça
c'est l'expérience qui lui permet
contrairement à quelqu'un qui va
imaginons je prends quelqu'un dans la
salle qui n'a jamais boxé il vit
exactement la même chose sa réaction la
grande probabilité ce sera déjà
hasardeuse mais la grande probabilité
ce sera ça
ça fait mal mais on en survie
ok
moi j'ai envie de dire un peu plus loin
et de revenir finalement à
comment comment se fait et comment on
fait pour finalement que ce champion qui
était pas champion au départ il s'est
mis à se lancer vers cet objectif
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'ils aient un
moment donc c'est bien bien bien avant
il s'est lancé vers cet objectif est
ambitieux
qu'est ce qu'il faut pour commencer
et il faut se sentir confiant il faut se
sentir motivé il faut se sentir capable
de rester focalisé sur l'action capable
de garder un état d'esprit ouvert
capable de pouvoir gérer son stress ses
émotions face à l'adversité il faut se
sentir capable et comment on fait pour
sentir capable c'est là où en fait il va
falloir se sentir en équilibre en
équilibre avec soi même et l' équilibre
de soi même c'est en fait la
connaissance de notre système notre
système sénou entièrement et l'
équilibre dans notre système quand on se
sent en équilibre il se passe quelque
chose c'est qu'en fait ça va nous aider
à percevoir le chemin
comme beaucoup plus facile à faire et en
plus ça va nous permettre de nous sentir
beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup plus plus
confiant en gros le fait de se sentir
bien avec soi même
permet de
voir la difficulté devant soi un petit
peu atténué nous un petit peu plus
confiant un peu comme superman
cet équilibre donc maintenant comment on
fait pour être en équilibre en fait cet
équilibre il repose sur nos besoins
essentiels et universel en gros il
repose sur notre connaissance à nous de
comment notre système fonctionne comment
on fait pour mettre en marche cette
machine là à prendre les meilleures
décisions possibles comment il fait eh
ben il va falloir répondre à nos besoins
essentiels et ça on oublie souvent par
contre les champions les athlètes ils
apprennent très très très très
rapidement à connaître ses besoins
essentiels ses besoins essentiels c'est
notre sommeil la connaissance de son
sommeil c'est la connaissance de sa
nutrition c'est la connaissance de notre
activité bah c'est de faire de
l'activité physique évidemment et c'est
aussi l'activité sociale on est des
êtres sociaux on a besoin d'être les uns
avec les autres d'avoir des relations
saines pour pouvoir se sentir équilibré
on a besoin bouger se sentir équilibré
on a besoin besoin de nutriments d'eau
pour tout simplement se sentir déjà
vivant sentir vivant dans le sens vivre
et puis le sommeil très très important
et puis un autre aspect qui est souvent
oubliée c'est l'environnement
l'environnement dans lequel on est on a
besoin d'un environnement où on se sent
en sécurité
si on est en insécurité si on a un de
ces essentiels qui n'est plus là on est
en total déséquilibre
maintenant je vais vous le montrer avec
une un exemple de profite qui a fait en
2013 une étude justement et qui a montré
par cette étude je vais la simplifier
mais à quel point selon ce que l'on fait
donc nos actions au quotidien nos
actions dans le fait qu'on mange que
l'on est fatigué ou pas à une à une
action un impact sur notre perception du
chemin qui demande la le but c'était
d'observer un chemin il ya une certaine
pente et le but était de demander à la
personne
comment il
commet la pente et pour lui comment elle
est si elle est plutôt élevé il devait
montrer à peu près le degré de la pente
et ben en fait il ya eu
plein de conditions différentes pour
pouvoir vérifier la perception de la
personne et ce qu'on a constaté c'est
que s'il m avec un ami il perçoit la
pente comme beaucoup moins plus faibles
s'il a un sac à dos sur le dos bah là il
la perçoit comme beaucoup plus élevé si
on vient de lui faire faire une tâche
cognitive qui était compliqué il va la
percevoir comme beaucoup plus difficile
si sa posture aussi s'il est avachi ou
s'il est justement dans la posture de
superman il va pas du tout percevoir la
pente de la même manière je vous laisse
deviner lequel nous permet d'être
beaucoup plus confiant évidemment c'est
la posture de superman ou superman
excusez moi
et surtout de manière inconsciente c'est
au niveau de la nutrition en gros le
taux de glycémie dans le sang a un
impact sur notre perception du chemin en
gros il avait donné des canettes de soda
goût sucré pour l'un en fait c'étaient
des additifs et pour l'autre c'était
vraiment du sucre ce qu'avait du sucre
donc qu'ils étaient c'est notre énergie
le glucose c'est l'énergie qui fait
fonctionner notre cerveau et notre
organisme celui qui avait véritablement
le sucre sachant qu'il ne le savait pas
il percevait la plante comme plus facile
pour vous montrer à quel point
ben les relations sociales l'état
physique la fatigue la posture taux de
glycémie et j'en passe un impact sur
notre perception des choses
et donc notre capacité à pouvoir faire
les choses
donc quand on arrive à contrôler et à
connaître chacun de ces mécanismes l'a
finalement comprendre comment notre
meilleur algorithme bouquet dans notre
tête puissent fonctionner au mieux grâce
à nos besoins essentiels c'est là on
commence à se donner les capacités à
peut-être se mettre sur ce chemin qui
est plutôt ambitieux
maintenant j'ai envie de parler de
quelque chose qui est important pour moi
c'est aujourd'hui
notre ignorance de finalement tout s'est
tu toutes ces influences que l'on fait
au quotidien toutes ces actes que l'on
fait au quotidien a une influence sur
notre environnement
donc finalement sur notre planète
chacune des choses que l'on fait chaque
par exemple on porte pour la nutrition
je prends sur le sucre
une
j'achète une
comment pâte à tartiner on sait que
dedans il ya du sucre ont cédé devant il
ya du cacao on sait que dedans il ya de
l'huile de palme on adore ça c'est un
plaisir très facile parce que c'est du
sucre il se trouve que le cerveau il
adore le sucre mais il fait pas lundi
suis en train bons nutriments et un
mauvais nutriments par contre ce mauvais
nutriments vu que c'en est un mauvais il
a un impact énorme parce que pour faire
venir le sucre eh ben on sait comment on
sait je sais pas si vous savez comment
ça se passe mais au niveau de la canne à
sucre qui est fait c'est fait par
exemple au brésil et que pouvoir faire
en masse ce genre de sucre qu'est ce
qu'il faut il faut des plantations pour
que ces plantations elle puisse pousser
rapidement il faut qu'il y ait de la
terre et pour que cette terre elle
puisse fournir et bien on met des des
produits qui aident énormément à
produire mais seulement une seule fois
équilibristes totalement notre terre du
coup qu'est ce qui se passe il ya une
désertification qui se passe donc on va
sur un autre endroit et c'est exactement
ce qui s'est passé et ce qui se passe
depuis des années c'est pour ça
qu'aujourd'hui eh ben la manière dont on
se nourrit un impact sur notre
environnement et au final un autre
environnement
voilà ce qui se passe
la manière dont on fait aujourd'hui
chaque action que l'on a un impact sur
notre environnement
le seul souci les amis c'est que
ce système là
il dépend de notre planète et je dis pas
la planète c'est notre planète et
chacune
chacun des essentiels et dépendant de
l'environnement dans lequel on est
et en fait libé et l'hypothèse peut-être
utopique c'est que comme je les dis
chacun on ne peut pas contrôler les
autres par contre on peut se contrôler
soit comme un athlète il ne peut pas
contrôler son adversaire il va se
contrôler lui si chacun d'entre nous
parce qu'on a un poids sur cette terre
si chacun d'entre nous arriverons à
finalement se mettre un objectif qui est
le sien en tête et qu'on commence à agir
comme un ou une championne
avec en faisant attention finalement à
ses actions au quotidien pour développer
ses besoins et sont essentielles alors
peut-être peut-être qu'on arrivera
à rééquilibrer
finalement notre environnement
écologique à rééquilibrer notre
environnement social parce qu'évidemment
on aura des meilleures relations
sociales qui parle pas juste au niveau
de la nutrition et où je parle vraiment
à tous les niveaux on aura peut-être une
meilleure un meilleur environnement
professionnel évidemment vu plus sociale
c'est le professionnel et du coup on
aura certainement un environnement
personnel qui sera beaucoup plus aboutie
et tout ce que je veux dire c'est que
on va pas devoir attendre quoi que ce
soit on va devoir agir aujourd'hui on
connaît les données on connaît tous sa
par contre ce qu'on oublie c'est à quel
point notre poids notre action a une
influence sur nous sur notre
fonctionnement mais également sur les
personnes qu'il soit autour de nous et
finalement ces personnes ont aussi une
influence sur les autres personnes et à
force c'est comme ça que le poids et que
la dynamique va pouvoir changer je
l'espère pour nous tous pour qu'on
arrête de juste
survivre mais qu'on recommence à vivre
parce que depuis certain temps c'est de
la survie et le but pour tout le monde
sait qu'on puisse vivre
voilà
[Applaudissements]